so tell me about this record it's you
nip produced by hitboy produced by hit
boy o yeah it's on the album it's on the
album I'm I'm lowkey ready to drop that
right now you feel me but you know I I I
I'll let y'all wa for it man let y'all
press was this a record you guys uh cuz
I always had heard about the hit boy ni
SE I think it was like the session that
rxs in the middle was recorded uh was
this something you guys worked on when
he was alive around that time yeah there
something that we worked on um in 2018
you feel me and
um you know we just spice up the beat
just a little bit right you know what I
mean cuz it's 2023 now of course so you
know we made it make sense I really
excited anytime we got new nipy coming n
for sure I know last time uh when you
came on the show you had uh dropped
tidbits that may or may not have gotten
you in trouble about there being a nipy
Hustle No I didn't give me a trouble but
that [__] hit the blog that sh went
everywhere and and then I was just only
thing and then there was people who were
like yeah right he's lying like I'm like
bro like if he anybody would know it
might be him like yeah you feel me like
come on man like and then all I said was
like bro got so much music like I'm
pretty sure it's for show gonna be
another nip album is there an update
there I mean [__] what you think bro you
don't think it's going to be has to be
another nip album come on man cuz like
you said you he has so much unreleased
music it just has to be done the right
way that's the only thing is like yeah
it ain't going to get put out just cuz
cuz because you know right cuz I almost
think like when Pac passed there was
like a couple of them albums that were
rough but the first like one or two do
you remember me and then um the one that
had uh the the the the acoustic uh thugs
mansion on it was hard oh uh what's what
which one was it better better days was
fire better days had some [__] but then
there was like the [__] that like he was
working with like artists he would have
never have worked with him when he was
alive yeah bro like um what was that uh
he had like a song with Eminem and uh
bro Eminem did the whole album bro he
produced
heird and did
because you bro you had to get used to
hearing Pac on Eminem Beach it was more
like some mashup like [__] yeah that's
right it was that's that's that's all it
you know I mean like I'm aan I'm mem you
know I mean but to hear on M beat bro it
just kind of it wasn't I wasn't ready I
wasen ready for it it it was a little
weird for sure it'd be like if it would
have been dope if like some of the OG
producers Pac was working with came and
took some of those stems yeah curated
something like did the right way Dazz in
to do some production you know what I'm
saying that's the right way to do it
Superfly bring D Superfly in there you
feel me should maybe Dre yeah you feel
me and then yeah Dre can do the mixing
even quick too call Quick in you feel me
quick G come on man quick could have did
that whole album that have been crazy
and it would have been more it would
have been more like uh you know it would
have sounded like a Tupac album n it
definitely would have sound with quick
and uh pound like crazy for sure man yo
it's crazy too like obviously you're a
big poac fan thug life
too uh it's kind of crazy to see there's
finally like all these years later
someone got arrested for his death
what's that Tupac's death man that [__]
crazy bro and then we still don't even
know yeah we still don't even know what
to believe man you know I mean and
that's the thing is like it feels I mean
look as like a fan I mean you don't want
to ever see anybody go to jail yeah but
like but why but why so long though like
the thing is is that this that's why
that's that's what seemed tricky is like
you've been hearing the same story all
along all along all along like why y'all
wait 30 years this guy was doing all
these interviews and he's been doing
interviews when [__] they eventually I
think I think he's done so many
interviews that it had to finally like
come across like bro yeah your time Las
Vegas Metro is like like radar where
they're like wait this guy's wait what
like we should go see if this cuz cuz I
I always tell people like the Tupac they
probably pinched him you know what I
mean just
to get some more just to get some more
information and and to me the Tupac and
Biggie murders were very different like
the Tupac murder was some retaliation
[__]
that really wasn't didn't have it was
some Street [__] that that popped off in
one night as opposed to like the biggie
[__] was like a hit and depending on who
you listen to like the LAPD off duty
cops might have been involved like I
don't think the LAPD wanted to solve the
biggie murder because it would have made
them look crazy the Tupac murder was
just
like you know Orlando Anderson died and
that was who everybody was saying it was
the you know the guy behind it so this
dude's been doing all these interviews
[__] got to stop to self
snitching bro yeah this [__] crazy bro
like people just just just people
literally snitch on themselves just for
the views man for real it's crazy you se
you seen that interview with no jumper
when he asked uh yeah ask for question
he
said he's like all right so I mean you
know he didn't know how to handle it
after that he yeah he he was supposed to
come on the show uh earlier this morning
but um we
rescheduled I didn't know cuz he I
didn't know I had him come early cuz I
don't I don't know La politics I don't
know if you guys get along I don't know
n it's all good you feel me no but you
know I I don't know if if I ever have
two La rappers in the same day sprad out
[__] the Earth is my turf I love that
you know what I mean I go anywhere I
walk anywhere if I run it or whoever
it's going to be what it's going to be
if it's respect it respect if it ain't
it ain't you know I mean that clip uh
was very funny though you see that clip
yeah X4 was just like Adam asked him if
he was involved in some shootout on a
video and he just looked at him like
this yeah I like damn and I think you've
shown like um I gave you props last time
like when you and trell did that
interview on no jumper that was like a
big deal yeah for sure I went I went out
of town I was somewhere out of town I
ran into one of his homies and [__] he
like yeah man I'm from hu man I seen
that video you did with my homie you
feel me no I just think that [__] should
be like an example for the Young
Generation so you see like
the the the difference and the respect
level you feel me like yeah I think like
cuz I told him I'm like you know
[__] either gonna hate it or
love it he like both yeah he like they
going to hate it or they going to love
it you know what I mean like it is what
it is but so what you feel me yeah I
just think it's like it's it's important
to be able to show people like you know
we can break the cycle and some of my
homies knew who he was like when I let
the homies know like you feel me like
they knew who he was I mean show shout
out to T yeah man you know great guy
salute um so next year for sure 12
albums for sure already already put it
see one thing about me once I put out
all right so I got my January album
ready okay so that's ready mix and
master ready so we're going from
November 22nd to the January album
straight into the January album damn you
ain't playing yeah and I thought about
I'm like damn I need to give you know
success some time to breathe you feel me
T show and all that but like you know
with the game right now bro the years
it's going to be a new year yeah music
industry kind of resets for people who
don't know that's what I'm saying so
it's really all on like who going who
going who going to go to hard as soon as
the bar drop so that's why I say when
the bar drop I drop you feel me January
1st oh that's when the albums dropping
yeah oh [__] okay right away right away
bro no I ain't giving nobody no room bro
no breathing room bro I'm not playing I
love it yeah 25 a no brace for real man
in the flesh I love it man
for you have you um obviously nip you
guys just did a uh a dope show was it at
the Roxy you guys all did uh the was it
Roxy or l no LR L is a little bit more
bigger than Roxy I was it was either
Roxy or L we was going to originally do
it at the Roxy but um have been too
small exactly we need we needed a little
bit more expansion but obviously he was
so good at like curating artists
bringing you know artists on to the to
the team is that something you want to
do as well put the Co had on eventually
and definitely Talent um for sure you
know like I said you know when when the
when the when the year drop I'm also
going to announce you know what I mean a
couple of my artists oh so you've
already done that I've been doing music
with yeah cuz you know they they going
to drop too so I'm and is that a is that
258 it's 258 yeah no breaks for sure so
I got I got a good I got I got some good
management going on some marketing you
feel me PRS
yeah we locked in man you feel me I'm to
take this label [__] to another level
yeah you had to have learned so much too
just being around everybody you've been
around to where you can kind of like
apply so much of the game that you've
gotten over the years yeah you got to
think about it like we grew up we grew
up we grew up watching you know the
Masterpiece you know what I mean the the
the uh the easy EAS the Su kns the
Jermaine the PRI you feel what I'm
saying like they had a CEO mentality you
feel what I'm saying that's why I just
did the uh the soundtrack for the movie
Bon pie I just saw that yeah exactly so
you know I grew up you know death roll
all the soundtracks what Above the
Rim come on bro I don't even know what's
going on with soundtracks anymore cuz
the soundtracks back in the day that's
what I'm saying so I'm trying to bring
that back you feel me like we got a good
La movie going on all right let me put
some la music behind it you feel me let
me make the soundtrack for it let me
grab some artists from here from there
make a yeah create a whole soundtrack n
that's dope I mean [__] the last time
someone did that and killed it I think
was black panther black panther Kar
killed that man shout out that was a
good album had s so RB on there oh yeah
Mazy was on there Mazy was on there I'm
like oh yeah we looking good yes and
that was like 20 17 or 18 to like so
like it was I was like finally mazy's
getting like a look and I was like that
was like it wasn't kendri Lamar album
but that was like it was about as much
when he didn't put out an album you had
to be like all right that was like M&M's
8 Mile it was like it's kind of like em&
this about as close to Eminem albums you
can get like Kendrick's fingerprints all
over the album that 8 Mile soundtrack
was crazy boy